WE’RE GOING TO SPEAK TO TOM
HOMAN IN A MOMENT.
LET’S SPEAK WITH ALEX HOGAN
LIVE AT THE BORDER IN MISSION,
TEXAS.
>> HI, GOOD MORNING.
JUST OVER THIS LEVY THERE IS A
PROCESSING SITE WHERE MANY
MIGRANTS WHO SURRENDER TO
BORDER PATROL ARE PROCESSED.
WE’VE SEEN SOME OF THEM ALREADY
HERE THIS MORNING.
ALL OF THEM SHARING HARROWING
STORIES OF WHAT THEY’VE
EXPERIENCED IN THE JOURNEY JUST
LIKE THE LITTLE BOY.
LET’S TAKE A LISTEN.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
>> THIS CHILD JUST WALKS UP TO
BORDER AGENTS SOBBING.
HE WAS TRAVELING IN A GROUP
WITHOUT HIS FAMILY.
HE EXPLAINS THEY LEFT HIM
BEHIND WHILE HEADING TO THE
BORDER AND CRYING.
HE ASKED THE AGENT WHERE ELSE
WOULD HE GO IF HE DOESN’T GO
WITH THEM?
THIS IS A SAD NEW MILESTONE
THAT WE’RE SEEING.
19,000 CHILDREN ARE IN U.S.
CUSTODY.
EACH OF THEM JUST LIKE THAT
LITTLE BOY MADE IT ALL THE WAY
TO THE BORDER.
ONE BOY LAST WEEK WAS TRAVELING
WITH HIS FATHER, THE TWO SWAM
ACROSS THE RIO GRANDE RIVER BUT
THE FATHER DROWNED HELPING HIS
SON GET ACROSS.
THAT IS JUST ANOTHER ONE OF THE
TRAGIC STORIES OF THESE
CHILDREN ARRIVING HERE IN THE
U.S. UNACCOMPANIED.
MORE DELEGATIONS ARE ANNOUNCING
TRIPS TO THE BORDER TO SEE THIS
HUMANITARIAN CHALLENGE FOR
THEMSELVES.
ENVOY TO THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS SET TO RETURN
FROM HIS TRIP TO THE NORTHERN
TRIANGLE TOMORROW.
A LIVE LOOK AT THE BORDER WALL
IN MISSION, TEXAS.
MANY ENVIRONMENTAL ACTIVISTS
SAY THEY’RE GLAD, THIS NEVER
SHOULD HAVE BEEN BUILT.
WHILE LAW ENFORCEMENT SAY THE
HALTED PROGRESS REALLY CREATES
PROBLEMS OF ITS OWN.
>> YOU ARE PATROLLING AND
TRYING TO PATROL AND ENFORCE
AREAS THAT ARE WIDE OPEN.
YOU COUPLE THAT WITH
UNACCOMPANIED CHILDREN, FAMILY
UNITS AND YOU CAN’T FORGET THAT
EVERY DAY CRIMINAL ELEMENTS
ALSO.
>> AN EXAMPLE OF ONE OF THOSE
SECTIONS OF THE WALL NOT
FINISHED.
A LOT OF DIVIDED OPINIONS WHAT
TO DO.
MANY PEOPLE AROUND THE AREA
WANT QUESTIONS ABOUT WILL IT
GET FINISHED OR REMAIN LIKE
THIS?
QUESTIONS THEY’RE HOPING
THEY’LL GET FROM THE GOVERNMENT.
BILL AND DANA.
>> Dana: THANK YOU.
>> Bill: WANT TO BRING IN
FORMER ACTING ICE DIRECTOR TOM
HOMAN AND FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR.
WANT TO SHOW YOU THE NUMBER WE
WERE REFERRING TO A MOMENT AGO.
PROJECTED TOTAL UNACCOMPANIED
MINORS CROSSING THE BORDER THIS
YEAR 184,000.
TOM, YOU SAW THE VIDEO.
WHAT DO YOU THINK WHEN YOU SEE
THAT?
>> WELL LOOK, THANK GOD THAT
LITTLE BOY IS SAFE WITH THE
BORDER PATROL.
LOOK, THAT’S WHY I FIGHT SO
HARD, BILL.
PEOPLE ALWAYS ASK ME WHY DO YOU
GET SOME EMOTIONAL TV AND YELL
AN CONGRESS WHEN I TESTIFY.
THEY HAVEN’T SEEN WHAT I’VE
SEEN IN MY 35 YEARS.
I’VE FOUND MANY DEAD CHILDREN
AND TALKED TO WOMEN RAPED OVER
20 TIMES.
A THIRD OF EVERY WOMAN THAT
COMES ACROSS PUTS THEMSELVES
WITH A CRIMINAL CARTELS, A
THIRD MAKE THAT TRIP GET
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED.
I’VE DONE INVESTIGATIONS WHEN A
MIGRANT COULDN’T PAY A
SMUGGLING FEE WAS TORTURED HIM
WHILE HIS FAMILY IS ON THE
PHONE TO MAKE HIM PAY THE FEE
AND KILLED HIM IF THEY DIDN’T.
FEMALES GET RAPED.
I TALKED TO A 9-YEAR-OLD WHO
WAS RAPED.
I DID A LOT OF INVESTIGATION
AND PUT A LOT OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKERS IN PRISON.
I COULDN’T PUT THEM ALL IN
PRISON.
THESE CARTELS ARE RUTHLESS.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION, THE
PROMISES THEY’VE MADE ABOUT YOU
CAN ENTER THE COUNTRY AND YOU
WON’T BE DEPORTED OR DETAINED.
WE’LL GIVE YOU AMNESTY AND FREE
HEALTH CARE.
YOU CAN PUT THE MOST VULNERABLE
PEOPLE TO PUT THEMSELVES IN
HARMED WAYS TO GET HERE BECAUSE
THEY THINK THEY WILL BE
RELEASED.
THEY’RE NOT HUMANE AS THEY SAID
IT WAS.
THE BORDER PATROL AGENTS SAVE
LIVES.
I WILL ADD THIS.
YOU CAN HATE PRESIDENT TRUMP OR
LIKE HIM.
I DON’T CARE.
YOU CAN’T ARGUE WHEN ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION WAS DOWN HOW MANY
WOMEN DIDN’T GET RAPED AND HOW
MANY CHILDREN DIDN’T DIE AND
HOW MANY MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
DID THE CARTELS NOT MAKE EVERY
DAY?
I THINK THIS ADMINISTRATION,
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION NEEDS
TO GET BACK TO SOME OF THESE
POLICIES.
THE POLICIES TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION HAD SAVED LIVES.
>> Dana: ANOTHER ASPECT OF ALL
THIS IN ADDITION TO CHILDREN
AND VICTIMS OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION AND WHAT CARTELS
ARE DOING TO THEM.
THE POSSIBILITY THAT WHEN THEY
SAY 100,000 GETAWAYS IN A
POSSIBLE YEAR COULD INCLUDE
TERRORISTS.
TWO FROM YEMEN HAVE BEEN CAUGHT
ALREADY.
DON’T KNOW HOW MANY HAVEN’T
BEEN CAUGHT.
KEVIN MCCARTHY SAID THIS LAST
NIGHT ON HANNITY.
>> THE BORDER AGENTS TOLD ME
THEY HAD CAUGHT PEOPLE ON THE
TERRORIST WATCH LIST.
WHEN I BROUGHT THAT UP AT THE
PRESS CONFERENCE MY DEMOCRATIC
COLLEAGUES WERE SHOCKED BY IT.
THEY CALLED ME A LIAR.
UNTIL WE BROUGHT FORTH THE
ANSWERS.
IT SHOULD NOT COME AS A
SURPRISE THE DEMOCRATS ARE
TROUBLED BY THIS.
THEY ARE TRYING TO DISTRACT
FROM THIS DISASTER BECAUSE THEY
CREATED IT.
>> Dana: WHEN THERE IS CHAOS IN
A SITUATION TERRORISTS LIKE TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF IT AND LIKE
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF A
TRANSITION FROM ONE
ADMINISTRATION TO THE NEXT.
>> GREAT QUESTION.
THAT’S WHAT MAKES THIS
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS A NATIONAL
SECURITY CRISIS.
THE BORDER PATROL HAS SAID 40%
OF THEIR MANPOWER IS NO LONGER
ON THE LINE.
IF YOU’RE SOMEBODY IN THE WORLD
WANTS TO DO US HARM AND BLOW
SOMETHING UP.
YOU CAN’T GET A PLANE TICKET.
IT IS ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE TO GET
A VISA BECAUSE OF ALL THE
DATABASE CHECKS.
THEY LOOK FOR ANY DEROGATORY
INFORMATION AND SECURITY
PROGRAM PROTECTS THE ISSUANCE
OF A VISA TO SOMEONE WHO HAS
DEROGATORY INFORMATION RELATED
OR KNOWN OR SUSPECTED TERRORIST.
IF YOU REALLY WANT TO COME TO
THE COUNTRY WHAT’S THE BEST WAY?
COME THE SAME WAY THROUGH THE
SOUTHWEST BORDER WHEN 40% OF
BORDER PATROL ISN’T ON THE LINE.
THE BORDER IS VULNERABLE.
YOU SAID IT CORRECTLY.
HOW MANY GOT THROUGH THAT WE
DIDN’T CATCH?
THAT’S WHAT SCARES ME.
THERE IS OVER 1,000 GOTAWAYS
EVERY DAY BASED ON TRAFFIC THEY
CAN’T RESPOND TO OR DRONE OR
CAMERA TRAFFIC.
OVER 1,000 GOTAWAYS.
IF YOU WANT TO COME TO THIS
COUNTRY TO DO US HARM THE
BORDER IS VULNERABLE RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE OF THE SITUATION
CREATED BY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
>> Bill: A LOT MORE TO COVER
HERE.
IF YOU ARE ON THE NO-FLY LIST
YOU KNOW IT IF YOU’RE A
TERRORIST.
YOU PROBABLY TRIED TO GET ON A
PLANE ALREADY AND YET YOU AS WE
HAVE SEEN YOU CAN WALK ACROSS
THE BORDER IF YOU CAN GET THERE.
THANK YOU, TOM.
ONE FINAL NOTE ON THIS.
TALK NOW THEY COULD PLUG THE
HOLES, QUOTE, UNQUOTE IN SOME
OF THE BORDER WALL THAT WAS
UNFINISHED.
SEEMS LIKE A GOOD IDEA WHEN YOU
SEE VIDEO FROM THE AERIAL
PICTURES THERE.
THE GAPS ARE VULNERABLE RIGHT
NOW.
>> Dana: I FEEL IF THE BIDEN